[Music]
[Music]
hey what is up guys I'm kitty HD here so
remember the Back to the Future
self-lacing shoes the air mags that I
made a video about well that was a prop
you know a super limited edition almost
no one could get one but even if you did
you wouldn't wear them every day you'd
put them in a glass case and display
them for the world to see but shortly
after that we saw that Nike would
actually be making a real pair of
self-lacing shoes that people can
actually buy and wear in 2016 this is
those this is the nike hyperadapt 1.0
welcome to your Super HD exclusive first
look so off the bat this is one of the
first pairs you will see on the Internet
and this pair in particular is a custom
colorway that not everyone will be able
to get their hands on it's all white
damn Daniel so the one that you'll
actually be able to buy the ones that
you've seen the articles about will be
in the black color and they look a lot
more subtle in person actually prefer
them in that color but you can see with
the general shape here the hyper adapts
have that classic Nike style to them you
know looking a little bit like the older
Kobe's maybe a little bit of kairi's in
there I've no sneaker head by any means
I leave that to my cousins for the most
part but these look pretty clean I gotta
say now obviously the mags would look
crazy on your feet in public they're
like moon boots but these have done a
good job of looking like a normal shoe
while adding the ridiculously convenient
self-lacing feature these less on the
side and on the back are pretty cool and
they actually serve a purpose so after
you use the buttons they're to adjust
the final tightness same as the mag's UP
button to tighten down button to loosen
after you do all that the color the
lights glow at the bottom represents how
much battery life you have left so blue
is good to go yellow means you're
getting lower might want to think about
charging and red means low battery but
what's different is unlike the mags the
lights on the shoe don't stay on 24/7
when you're wearing them again they're
blending in so you don't need them on
all the time so that saves you a lot of
battery life so the hyper adapts should
last you a pretty comfortable two weeks
on a charge if not way more than that
now to recharge them this is actually
way better than mags you might be asking
how exactly do I get battery back in
these guys well in the massive box they
come in there's what looks like a weird
double stethoscope thing yeah that is
the wireless charger
yes these shoes have wireless charging
there's magnets in the chargers and
magnets in the bottom of the shoe that
are actually pretty powerful so I guess
while MagSafe may be gone in the new
MacBook Pros it lives on here in the 2
amp charger that connects to the bottom
of these shoes they take about 2 hours
to fully recharge from 0 and Nike reps
I've talked to have said they've worn
them for much longer than two weeks with
no problems so you can even charge them
up real quick from a power bank in case
of emergency
dead shoe battery situation that's a
very 2016 sentence so now that these
shoes already have a feature that plenty
of smart phones don't have it should be
pretty obvious that these are super
smart you know I consider them a piece
of tech just for that they also have a
memory to them so the automatic lacing
might not be the perfect snugness for
you but you can mess with it you can
adjust it on the go and then once you've
decided you like it you can hold both
buttons for a couple of seconds to set
that to the tightness as a preset so
next time you step into the hyper adapts
they will remember just how you like it
so this is it this is the first gen of a
new product and Nike is encouraging us
to actually like wear them around you
know wear them everyday put them to the
test and while I don't think I would
ever walk out of a Nike store with the
mags on my feet I can actually see these
being everyday shoes for people which is
the idea like considering there is a
motor a battery some magnets and LED
lights all in the bottom of the shoe
it's actually pretty lightweight like
under 15 ounces and the shape and
snugness have it pretty comfortable and
there's just something about having the
shoe lace up for you as soon as you step
in them fastest shoot I ever honestly
you don't realize how easy it isn't to
actually try it and to then be able to
stop in the middle of your day and press
the button for one second to tighten the
shoes is way easier and way faster than
untying and retying laces so basically
long story short if I'm thinking of
these shoes as a tech product that I'm
seeing them as like version 1.0 I mean
they're called hyperadapt 1.0 s-- so
similar to like the first generation of
smartphones or first generation of
tablets the tech inside has a long way
to go and you can kind of see it like I
mean they do a pretty good job of making
it look like regular shoes but you can
tell that they're not normal shoes so if
you're the type of person who would love
to hang on to like a first generation
iPhone or a g1 or a first gen product to
see what it ends up
looking like with the contrast of
today's tech then you're also the type
of person who would probably want to
hang on to a first-generation pair of
hyper adapts to see what they look like
next to shoes in like eight years which
is why I am giving mine away and it's
not just me it's me and my buddy John
from the TLD Today channel so you should
check out his channel he dropped a video
at the same time of these shoes as well
he's a size 11 he's given his pair way
I'm a size 13 I'm given my para way and
in case you're not the type to actually
want to wear them every day we'll throw
in some other tech to spice it up and
make it actually worth winning the
giveaway even if you don't wear the
shoes or happen to be our size so we're
gonna throw in a tech backpack we're
gonna toss in a battery bank and the
winner will also get the smartphone of
his or her choice so there are two of
these kits being given away all you have
to do to get entered is to drop a
comment right below that like button of
which smartphone you would want in your
pack and one of the winners will be
selected in exactly a week from today
and it will be announced on Twitter and
that person will get a pack again enter
on his channel as well sub to both of us
and get yourself entered so good luck
that's been it thank you for watching I
hope you enjoyed your exclusive first
look at the hybrid apps and I'll talk to
you guys the next one peace
[Music]